hello everyone i am subhishi patro and
today i will be talking about fine
grained complexity via quantum works
this is a joint work with harry booman
bruno loff and florian spelman
let's begin
of late a lot of money and effort is
going into quantum computing
that is because for many quantum very
many computational problems we have
quantum algorithms that are faster than
the classical ones
and rightfully so
because quantum computers are a more
powerful model of computation than the
classical computers
however
we also see that quantum speedup is not
guaranteed for all problems
let's look at some examples
for problems like integer factorization
and discrete log
we have quantum algorithms that are
exponentially faster than the classical
ones
but for problems like triangle finding
orthogonal vectors three sum c and f sat
the quantum speed up that we see is only
polynomial
and
for surprisingly for problems like
longest common subsequence edit distance
and pressure distance we don't give the
current quantum algorithms
are as
bad as the classical ones
so it would be nice if we could in any
way know for which problems
we have a quantum speed up and if there
is then how much
but
the state of the art is not so bad
there are some problems like unordered
search
where the quantum speed up is known to
be optimal
but for from some problems like
travelling salesman problem or cnf sat
the speed up is not known to be optimal
and in some other cases for example like
the case of recommendation algorithm we
thought we had an exponential quantum
speed up but it turned out that we did
not
so the natural question again to ask
is how much quantum speed up is possible
and how do we assert that
another uh line of direction
an unfortunate result was that
with this current known quantum eritre
error correcting techniques
there is no quantum advantage for
problems having only quadratic quantum
speedups for any practical input sizes
this was a recent result by bubba
shetter
but now
how can we show then that for what kind
of problems uh the best possible quantum
speed up is say quadratic
and we will soon see that we can do so
by proving lower bounds
for example
there is several
computational geometry problems for
which ambinus and larka in 2020
gave
almost linear algorithms
showing that a quadratic speedup for
these problems was possible if you use
quantum computers as opposed to
classical ones
and using our techniques we are able to
show that conditional on some reasonable
conjectures
uh the algorithms that ambinus and larka
gave for these problems are actually
optimal
and
again invoking this recent result by
purpose at all
uh
we can then see that for problems like
computational for problems such as these
computational geometry problems
it
quantum computing is not going to help
much at least in the near-term future
unless there is some significant
improvement in the error correcting
techniques
now the results that we prove here
use a family of technique called fine
grain complexity
but let me also bring to your notice
that
fine grained results in the quantum
setting has been
given for other problems such as closest
pair problem edit distance problem but
all these results are fairly new and
they just date about
one and a half year ago
but
now
i
i have been using this term lower bounds
and i will be using these terms upper
bounds and lower bounds also in my talk
and like in future
so let me briefly explain what upper
bounds and lower bounds mean in
complexity theory
now suppose you have this computational
problem and someone says there's an
upper bound for this problem now upper
bound for any problem is just the run
time
of the best algorithm that solves the
problem
while lower bound on the other hand is
the time required
for any algorithm that solves the
problem
and we say
the bounds are tight or we say the upper
bound that we have is the best algorithm
when the upper bound and lower bound
match for the problem
but the unfortunate situation is that we
do not know how to prove lower bonds
so how do we know whether the best known
like whether the upper bound that we
have is optimal or not
so we resort to a technique called fine
grain reduction
though it is fairly recent in the
quantum setting to prove fine-grained
results
it is
a
it's it's a
it's a very common uh not common but
it's a it's a
old method known in the classical
setting
but uh let me just briefly describe as
to what fine grain reductions look like
okay
now let's say we have this problem a
which
is very well studied
a lot of people have put effort in it
but for some reason it has the
reputation of being hard people are not
able to improve
or not able to find
fast algorithms for problem a
and now suppose there's a problem b
which is interesting
but for but it has not been studied as
much as problem a
and people don't know know how hard it
is to solve problem b
then
can we can we talk can we make any
statement or can we get any knowledge
about the hardness of problem b
based on what we know about problem a
and turns out that we can
if we are able to reduce problem a to
problem b
now what do i mean by reduction
a reduction is possible
if
for like if i am able to map these input
instance of problem a
to some input instances of problem b
and using an algorithm for problem b i
can solve actually problem a then i say
i we have a reduction from problem a to
problem b
now how is this going to help us
now it's going to help us in this way
suppose there was a faster algorithm for
problem b
then using this faster algorithm for
problem b
we can get a faster algorithm for
problem a
which we do not believe is possible
that means
there's
there is no faster algorithm for problem
b
so what we have done is
we have got a lower bound from prop for
problem b
based on a believed lower bound for
problem a
let me summarize again
so we pick a problem a which is believed
to be hard
we try to reduce problem a to problem b
then we conclude lower bound for problem
b using the believed lower bond from
problem a
and for the purpose of this talk
we picked the problem a to b threesome
problem
and we ended up proving lower bounds or
conditional lower bounds for
computational geometry problems
and for zero edge weight triangle
finding problem
now let me
give you a
flavor of what three sum problem looks
like especially given that this becomes
our central problem in proving certain
lower bounds
so this is a very um
easy problem to describe we have this
list s of n integers
and all we want to know whether or not
there exists
a triple a b c belonging to this list
such that they all sum to zero
let's look at an example this is a list
of six integers
and we can see that if we set a equals
to 1 b equals to 4 and c equals to minus
5 we have this triple which add up to 0.
now what do you think will be the
classical complexity for threesome
problem
so clearly there's this trivial n cube
algorithm
where you take all these n cube possible
triples
and check if any of these triple has
to
this
solution
but there's also a slightly less trivial
n square algorithm for this
let me briefly show you how
now take this list as
make a copy of it
that will cost you end time
now make a third copy
but this time sort the third copy
so this takes this requires additional
and login time
now
what we do is
we go over all these n square
n square pairs from the first two list
and we would like to see
if there exists an element in the third
list
that is negative of some of these
some negative of some of one of these
pairs
okay
and because this third list is sorted we
can do a binary search to search for
such an element
so the total time complexity for this
part becomes then n square log n
and
in fact there's an
other trick that we could use to even
improve this n square log n time
algorithm to actually give us a n square
algorithm
now
the
surprising part is
people are not able to
improve on these n square algorithm for
threesome in the classical setting
uh they have come up with some poly
logarithmic
uh
shaving off
but
that's about it
so it was and and for the purpose of
this talk we are going to ignore any
poly logarithmic factors of n
so it was ultimately natural to
conjecture that threesome requires n
square time on a classical computer
and but what use could this be of
it was in fact of very good use because
based on this conjecture
lower bonds for a lot of problems were
being able to establish
and that gave explanatory power as to
why people were not able to improve on
the
existing algorithms for a lot of
problems
but let me
slightly zoom in and show you
how to give you a flavor of how these
reduction look like okay
so let us pick this
reduction from threesome to zero edge
weight triangle finding problem
so we have this threesome problem which
we have already defined
and we have the zero edge weight
triangle finding problem
this is also an interesting problem
where we are given a graph of n nodes
with weighted edges meaning every edge
has a weight associated with it
and what we would like to know is if
there is a triangle
whose weight some of the weights of the
edges sum to zero
and
what this reduction implied is
if there was an n sub cubic algorithm
for zero edge weight triangle finding
problem
then
threesome could have a sub quadratic
time algorithm
which is based on this threesome
classical conjecture not believed to
exist
so
the zero edge weight triangle finding
problem cannot have a sub cubic
algorithm as long as the threesome
classical threesome conjecture is true
and
the the reduction
was actually a two-step reduction where
threesome was first reduced
from threesome to a sorted version of
threesome
by here i don't mean the usual sort that
we talk about not the one that where the
elements are sorted in ascending order
but in a some sort of a structuring some
sort of a
general sorting that threesome is
reduced to
yeah
but this general sorting also requires
uh uh
how to say
n log n or just linear amount of time
okay
and then
a non-trivial reduction from sorted
threesome was given to the zero edge
weight triangle finding problem
um
but
why are we talking about this classical
thing
we are all quantum people so we should
talk about all these in the quantum
setting
so now let's look at the quantum
algorithm for threesome
is it possible that for threesome given
that quantum computers are more powerful
than classical computers it's it's
possible that maybe threesome has a
faster than classical algorithm right
maybe
threesome has a faster quantum algorithm
than the classical one
in fact it turns out to be true
now let's look at the same algorithm
that we discussed the classical one for
threesome so we have this list
we have
one copy sorted so we have taken
additional n log n time
and we
have this other two
uh
copies of this list but now what we do
is
instead of using the classical algorithm
that
goes over all these n square pairs
and checks for an element whose sum
exists in this list with a negative sign
we actually grover over this n square
tuples
and because grover search is
quadratically faster than classical one
we are able to
um
do this entire
we're able to
you know quantize this entire classical
algorithm
in n log n time
so
now
given given that we are not able to find
any other classical faster classical
algorithm and given that that is a
conjecture in the classical setting as
to threesome requires n square time
it is natural to
conjecture that threesome requires end
time on a quantum computer
and uh
in a paper by ambience and larker
this conjecture was also
informally stated
but now what happens
to all these
lower bounds that we concluded based on
these classical reductions from
threesome to these computation geometry
or sequence problem or dynamic problems
or triangle connection or any of these
so let's look at this reduction from
threesome to zero h weight triangle
finding problem again
so we had this linear reduction from
threesome to sorted threesome
and we had this non-trivial classical
reduction from sorted threesome to zero
actuate triangle finding problem
and now we would like to see if any of
that still holds
now what we noticed is the reduction
from threesome to sorted threesome is
not at all trivial to port quantum day
but uh fortunately
the
non-trivial classical reduction from
sorted threesome to zero edge way
triangle finding problem was because it
was local we are able to actually
quantize that very easily
so now we would
like to try to fix the other thing
or
give a
whole new reduction from g sum to zero
into a triangle right
so we thought okay why not why not try
and fix this part
so we we and the other thing that we
also noticed that
was not just the threesome two not just
the reduction from threesome to zero
each weight triangle
even the reduction from threesome to a
vast collection of computational
geometry problem
involved a similar intermediate step
where threesome was supposed to be first
reduced to some version of sorted system
and then the sorted threesome or some
version of sorted threesome was to be
reduced to some
to one of the to all of these problems
but we don't know how to quantumly
reduce threesome to sorted season
that is because
because
sorting in the classical setting it
requires n log n time
but sorting in the quantum setting also
requires n log n time
so there is no sub linear sorting
algorithm for
input for us in the quantum setting
that's why the classical reductions fail
in that particular step to to be
directly ported into the quantum setting
and we give a work around for that and
we show using a quantum walk technique
that the sorted version of threesome are
equally as hard as threesome in the
quantum setting
and this is
what we are going to do now
but
a disclaimer here
uh this part this is a very technical
part of the talk
and one
people who are not very familiar with
the
quantum work uh query algorithm to solve
threesome
might find it a little difficult to
follow this part
now
recall the quantum work based query
algorithm for threesome problem
so what is the setup we have this
johnson graph
with parameters n and r
where r is
some n power beta where beta is between
0 and 1. so basically r is a polynomial
of n but
it's a
sub linear
polynomial
okay
now
each of this vertex ah kind of
represents
an r sized subset
of this instance of threesome problem
and we have edges connected from vertex
vi to vertex vj
only if it differs
in exactly one
index okay
and the notes that contain solution to
threesome problem are considered to be
marked
now what the quantum work algorithm does
is it tries to find this mark node in an
optimal number of queries
now please note i am talking about
queries right now
so the complexity of the work algorithm
turns out to have a nice formula of this
form
with s being the setup cost
n r
in this
product
c being the checking cost and then u
being the update cost
now again note that when i mean
complexity of this work algorithm
this
value holds for both the query algorithm
and for the time complexity as well
but now again we are back to query
algorithm so let's just talk about the
query complexity
so what we noticed
um
that
we can solve this
sort of threesome we can solve we can we
have a query algorithm that solves this
threesome problem
with setup cost being set to r the
checking cost is zero and the update
cost is two
but let me also explain um sorry i
forgot to explain what the setup cost
checking cost and update cost even mean
so the setup cost is actually the cost
of
storing all these queries
for every vertex and that is done in
superposition so it is only seen per
vertex okay
and as there are r elements in it
in about our
order our number of queries we are able
to store all these um
query values for every vertex
now the checking cost
is the number of queries required and
the checking cost in terms of query is
the number of queries required
to check
if a particular node is marked or not
now in this case this checking cost is 0
because
once we already have the queries
we are not going to query the oracle
again for the input for for checking
whether a node is marked or not we can
always refer to the queries that are
already stored and we can just check
that
and the update cost is the number of
queries required
for you to change
for you to traverse from one node to
another basically for one step of the
walk
so you are basically changing two
elements so that's why two queries
but what about the time complexity of
this work algorithm
oh by the way also one more thing so
this query algorithm turned out turns
out to be optimal
with and the uh the query algorithm also
turns out to be sublinear which is n
part three by four
and it is optimal by a lower bound given
by bellows
anyway now coming back to the time
complexity what about the time
complexity
now the if we try to use the same
algorithm and try to look at the time
complexity
what goes wrong is
yes we are able to uh do the setup in
almost linear
almost uh our amount of time
we are able to even achieve this update
with you know almost constant time now
this tilde over o or tilt over over here
just means there are polynomial factor
but we are not able to reduce this
checking cost any further
now an interesting idea would be
what if
we are able to store this our size
success in some structured way
that
you know
we we can
probably check this vertices like the
queries and the vertices in a faster way
is that possible
and it turns out that
using some data dynamic data structures
and such dynamic data structures exist
we can actually store these query values
in every node
in a ascending order
and
that
the the data structures are also so
efficient that they allow for
the data structure operations like
insertion or deletion or indexing to
happen in polynomic amount of
time
which for us anyway
are the factors that we don't care about
so now that we can use this dynamic data
structure to sort these elements
and keep it
so instead of
calling the
three sum
so for the checking algorithm
subroutine what we will now
end up calling
is
a sorted threesome subroutine for every
vertex
and because we'll be doing it in
superposition ah
it's it's pretty fine
now
now let's assume that sorted threesome
is easier than threesome and what do i
mean by easier
so till now we saw that threesome didn't
have sip like at least we believe that
threesome doesn't have a sub linear
quantum time algorithm
but let's say sorted threesome is easier
and let's say sorted threesome has a
sublinear quantum time algorithm
then by plugging in the values in the
equation with you know
the same equation but let me let me
address it by t
this s being almost
linear in r
c
strictly sub linear in r
and this update time being same that is
almost constant
because we are ignoring the polylogic
factor
we see that this total value of this
expression
actually can be made
significant which means
a sub linear algorithm for sorted
threesome
can be used to give us a linear
algorithm
for the
original threesome in the quantum
setting
but that is not supposed to be possible
unless we believe unless quantum
threesome conjecture is false
so
to repeat
if threesome requires linear time then
sorted threesome also requires linear
time in a quantum computer this is what
the result we get
in fact
using the same technique we are also
able to comment on the quantum hardness
of some other structured version of
threesome problems like here in this
example that i discussed it was the
sorted reason that i explicitly talked
about talked about but we are also able
to uh give a slightly more general
version of this
sorted threesome property
and
because of our proof strategy
we are now able to
put the classical reductions from
threesome to
this zero actuate triangle finding and
we are able to also quantize the quantum
classical reductions that exist from
threesome to this vast collection of
computational geometry problems
and as a result as a as an imp
as a result
we were able to prove a tight linear
lower pump yes it is conditional but we
are able to prove a tight linear lower
pump for zero edge weight triangle
finding problem
and we are also able to prove
linear lower bounds for
uh this list of computational geometry
problem
for most of which
the bound is tied but there are some
open problems
which are not yet closed there
and
to summarize
uh
we
see that fine grain reduction is a
promising way forward to be able to
prove super linear lower parts
to be more precise what it is able to
prove are the lower bounds that are
beyond the query law bonds
and using our proof strategy
we are
able to assert
uh the hardness of sorted versions of
threesome
which
though it is very trivial to prove in
the classical setting
it was
not at all trivial to
quantize those results in the quantum
setting
and
the last result is a bit cynical
but nevertheless it's an important
result because for many problems in
computational geometry we are able to
show that the speed up that we can get
in the quantum setting is at best
quadratic
which means
because of this recent result by publish
at all
uh we are not a
in the near near-term future quantum
computers might not be
a good bet for these
computational problems
and the future uh directions for our
project are also
numerous we still have a lot of these uh
reductions in the classical setting from
threesome to sequence problems or
threesome two dynamic courses into
triangle collection and matching
triangles
that are yet to be explored in the
quantum setting
and we believe our proof strategy is
going to uh
help us a lot there
but these are still things that are open
and
also
for many computational geometry not many
but there are these four computational
geometry problems here
for which we have linear lower bound but
we do not have a linear
upper bound yet
and so
that is still an open problem
until either we improve the upper lower
bound or we get
some better
algorithms
and
finally to conclude
we uh believe quantum fine grain
complexity opens an interesting way to
prove conditional time low bonds
and especially for problems
uh which have super
linear
algorithms
this seems to be the best way forward
and i would like to thank you for the
attention